robbie company vedo sei ragazzi non
company gioco di scrive il senso dei
quattro che è disponibile su xbox one
playstation 4 switch e picking store
bravo bravo complimenti bravo youtube
potete scaricarlo tramite il link che vi
lascio nella descrizione comunque se
volete anche supportarmi perché questo
gioco e sulle bighe in store potete
utilizzare sempre il codice creatore fa
vice in tv fatelo ragazzi così mi
arrivano i money grazie a proposito di
questo ragazzi ringrazio anche p games
per aver sponsorizzato il video comunque
ragazzi partiamo vediamo di che si
tratta di ragazzi sto per picchiare il
character non li conosco quindi vado a
simpatia non ho la più pallida idea io
ho bicchiere i ciak login
non so anche cosa fa però spero non
faccia cagare alla ragazzi la prima
partita è quella in cui in genere faccio
ma che figata
poi james jacques becker e l'intro di
questa è la intro dt della casa di carta
ragazze ragazzi aiuto come non ne
avrebbe spiegato che si pilota stappare
sta scendendo a gente rieccoli io noi
dobbiamo difendere gli obiettivi la
gente li deve attaccare molto semplice
abbiamo scelto fare una kill bello però
il fatto che sia in terza persona mi
destabilizza un sacco se devo essere
sincero però vediamo il supporto io o di
un uomo fatto ho fatto fuori il
pistolero va bene solo lui ho fatto
parte l'unico che vuol dire oddio oddio
è l'unico che è morto ma sono l'unico a
vivo ma dai ragazzi fate qualcosa
sto giocando solo io ma come ora appena
scaricato dove è possibile che sono
l'unico affare aver fatto nakheel
ma com'è possibile la salverò io la
situazione ragazzi ce la faccio 1.4 un
fenomeno
e vabbè è un peccato perché il porta
avanti non capito dovevo andare
bellissimo per balene ho capito molto
meglio
prendiamo delle armi decenti adesso
bravo alleluia ma lei solo tra una sola
esclusiva russa colasanto gesù state
calmi però è la madonna che male c'è
fatto malissimo curati bravo non
spuntano lo uccido se non spuntano luci
uno no fatto fuori le pistole cielo con
leo pistolero io ragazzino dai stavolta
ci affacciamo agilità di un tricheco
morto però mamma mia
vorrei ragazzi e li facciamo non ho
capito perchè non ti tolgono le armi
quando mori questa cosa ma non avevo mai
visto in un gioco del genere dove
complicarmi ogni round comunque ho fatto
un giro allucinante forse di pino
daniele
cioè non è detto perché magari siamo
spetterebbero loro frontex che ha
scritto a uno l'ho fatto fuori e
tensione c'è un altro per l'inizio dove
cacchio è proprio lui bravo mi ha dato
anche un punto in bravo non forse quello
il nome della squadra ma fa niente non
ho poi il bravo twitter
e vabbè una tua ma cosa ci fa qui levy
aiuto me qua a sparagli madonna reagan
che kim ciò i teletubbies giocano con me
ma dai
dal mio team secondo me qua per andiamo
perché attaccare facciamo schifo
poi magari mi sbaglio a voi giudicare un
altro personaggio
bene allora picchiamo n'è un altro
ragazzi più glitch leo pistolero l'ex
torero
mi dispiace le ho visto l'eroe non
volevo l'hanno rianimato attenzione dai
la violenza come un perfetto sono dietro
lui da pistolero sull ampio ragazze un
tizio non so cosa faccia questa ma oggi
oddio lanciato qualcosa e vabbè che chi
l'ho fatto lo ha visto l'euro andato giù
non so dove sia la nome arrivando a
destra e giusto dubbio che arrivano dove
appoggiare sajjadi trio occhi che ti
odio jolie era lo fisso nero che non
cela dietro tutti quanti ma non potevo
fare niente io ragazzi da solo non posso
fare tutto va bene ragazzi ultimo round
vediamo di perderla con dignità comunque
perché mi è piaciuta alla fine non è
andata male problema è che allo stato a
ciò io la bomba sono subito ok quindi il
peggio del peggio
oddio che uno zio qua ma dov'è ma che
camper maledetto chi sta pure bene
guarda maledetto camper schifo smi si
piazza la bomba
il gect in poi lo sta mettendo è
piazzato ma tutto io sto facendo sta
squadra un giocatore la prima partita mi
ha stoffa tutto io
madonna raga madonna
ma cosa vi stavo facendo sta facendo
tutti
vabbè ci sta comunque da solo non posso
fare quello che posto va bene va bene è
stata appena partita mi ha emozionato
mente male ragazzi devi provare l'altra
modalità che invece permette di fare più
sconti troviamo mxr signori andiamo
sulle mr proviamo a vedere se questa
arma ci rende giustizia letto questa
ragazzina modalità diversa perché quasi
dicono solo tre round per per arrivare
alla vittoria province trounson numero
di responso tali che puoi fare che sono
12 ci sono un numero di obiettivi da
recuperare che sono questi aspetta che
ci chiama le io comunque ho quest'arma
che secondo me a colpo leva tantissimo
però è colpo singolo ma cosa immune
aiuto vagone e aia cav al è immune cosa
comune quando a togliatti stanno
perdendo sono stiamoci non ho fatto
niente
l'ex grecia sono quasi morto per fare
questo shock ma tutto a posto dove che
sta la gente in tutto sulla mini c'è
solo uno ma che mira orribile spara gli
zii oddio lo sta vedendo è morto è morto
ma quando sono a zero vite basta
terminarli o che con questa armani fa
cagare scusa la tenera che affligge il
mio canale veramente orribile questa già
mi sa di più fattibile ha giocato molto
bene i miei compagni e sono veramente
forti diversamente da prima comunque
molto bene stata positiva ma non devo
fare tutto io k inizia da giocare
madonna potuto tolto e mori apporto
apposto un andato un andato
devo lasciarmi io sono qua eh vabbè
quanta gente c'è uno dietro uno davanti
uno da rovescio madonna kate shot
bellissimo
perfetto ok ci stiamo riprendendo lo ha
fatto nei 18 pazzesco mi è piaciuto un
sacco di dio mi chiama che matrix ha
schivato tutto punto scrivono male che
l'ha fatto fuori l'altro che lo di star
bene non l'ho preso però passato a fare
il giro a prenderlo da dietro chiamo
madonna no bellissima dichiarazione che
ho fatto
eccolo maledizione
ok riprendo io è l'obiettivo a posto ho
fatto io ho fatto io do fuori sono stato
bravissimo per la sua grande bob
devo mettermi qua dietro che se vedo
qualcuno arriva eccolo lino guarda
quell'altro dove mai sparato è la
madonna ma chi è quello e forti manca
solo lui già facciamo fuori tutti è la
l'ho visto l'ho visto stai tranquillo
che spam i loro visto però è difficile
farlo fuori
ok ciao lo seccato a prescindere ma
anche se non serviva prima fa niente
bella partita grande chi l'inter mi ha
dato
perfetto dai ragazzi l'ultimo round che
vince solo questo teoricamente doveva
andar bene speriamo canoa viene mi sa
che mi che ha subito puntato una destra
per caso ma per caldo
mannaggia buonissimo
e fatta è fatta e fate parte fatta
occhio oa chiarato l'obiettivo
siamo qua metto anche questo per terra
che non so se serve ma va beh oddio ma
posso prendere il cecchino ma richiama
attimo madonna ma che chi lo voglio
provarlo ragazzi di provare l'essenza
stracolmo ford ka trottola che è male
kim ha sparato così ma che dolore finale
e vabbè testa un tipo la madre location
pazzesco oddio di odiosa riva notizia
equa e non lo becco mairago non secoli
perfetto no era mancato di niente oddio
l'ho preso ragazzi ho fatto una
partitona costo fucile pensavo di fare
schifo invece guarda la pazzesco quello
al mio amico sparato ma fa niente dai
sono tutti per terra farli fuori tutti
ma già stato ma così è stato hai una
bomba ma noi siamo su un dardo
tracciante tipo una bomba non avevo idea
che pirla non sapevo e non lo stato
poteva saperlo raga pensa forse di un
dardo tracciante strana come bomba bello
ma cos'è che sparano gli altri non so
abbiamo vinto ha sparato dei missili ma
non lo capiva lei comunque non importa è
stata una gran partita rabbia ho fatto
un miliardo di chi meno male perché
adatta meglio questa al quale prima
abbiamo imparato meglio a giocare
fighissimo comunque c'è chi no non ho
capito potessi raccoglierà di per terra
pensavo di poter usare solo la mia arma
bellissimo figo è stato bello signori
spero che vi sia piaciuto questo qua era
rock company ragazzi mi raccomando se
volete scaricarlo mettete anche il mio
codice creatore come vedete all'iniziale
video fa deejay tv
indicato la visione del video lasciatemi
piace e noi come sempre ci rivediamo ad
un prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]